they said that they can detain me right
now
oh I'm being arrested TJ
do you have any weapons are you
what's going on here you're gonna talk
Tuesday
hear my phone over there sure okay okay
right there yeah we'll go with you
you're just really doing this
no sir you ever do this yeah
sir he did
the guy that's recording yes okay he's
the one that
well you were right here
you know that
and first of all you cannot detain me
right now wait yes
I think that they said that they can
detain me right now you're being
arrested oh I'm being arrested TJ
for what
we're standing still they're being drunk
in public
go ahead and have a seat sir
hold on hold on just one second
uh do you have my phone please yeah we
got it yeah
everything was with it dried easier
however you want to put it if you want
to turn it that way
commercial it does not go that way all
right well I've got like a bunch of room
I can put I'll put another set of Cups
on stop that's what they did if you want
another set of Cups on to where it's not
as tight don't move okay you understand
that sir yes
I don't understand what you guys are
doing and why
whenever you want to move
not listen to simple commands sir
you're giving a couple opportunities to
walk away
simple
what
what was that
that's my bad mood
all right
all right yeah
this will be good
what's that
first of all
what
on the back side of my phone please
now the back right there pull out the
card right there yeah and call your
sergeant
all right I am Sergeant no you're you're
leading officer before you take him
anywhere read the back
of that card
read it with state law says
okay
I'm gonna stand up please
yeah just just have to see it right
there all right
Oklahoma's House of Representatives
issued to representative Dean Davis of
Oklahoma for the purpose of identifying
the person remember Congress member of
Representative Constitution
foreign
okay well so the Privileges arrests
speeches or debates senators and
representatives ciao except for treason
honey or breach of peace be privileged
from arrest during the session of the
legislature correct and in going to and
returning from the same correct and for
any speech or debate in either house or
shall not be questioned in any other
place correct you're not in legislature
yes I am okay well it's you're not in
the state capital right now
fine call your call your advisor call
everyone hey TJ TJ yes I don't I don't
answer to TJ no you don't but so they're
going to call you if you're instead of
talking if you'll listen for just a
minute okay
so at this point right now
the way I'm reading it
you're not I'm not arresting you at the
same legislature or going to or from I
can and I am right now
so have a seat and I will run to pass my
supervisor you will
I already told you I will so go ahead
and have it locked up to me and just I
we gave you and your friends ample
opportunity to leave you're remaining at
a business that is supposed to be closed
you know and you're already obviously
intoxicated have a seat put your feet
down yes
hey by the way thank you for this myself
can I ask why you guys rolled up so fast
and just like basically
bombarded us
is it was 212.
in the morning yeah
and you're not you know the bars are
closed at at two
there's not supposed to be anybody on
the premises
at two
we go up there and you're still holding
a beer
along with your your buddies are still
drinking and you're not supposed to be
okay
my supervisor tells you guys y'all need
to go and I put mine down you continued
on no you did not yes I did I put it on
the table it's over there you didn't you
did not until after two different times
of telling you that you need to go I put
it down yes you did and then I started
walking away and then you grabbed my arm
because how can I Mr Davis I'm not going
to discuss this any further with you
uh all you want to do is as a is just
try to twist words
because you cannot exactly what you're
doing anything out of my pocket and show
you even my phone or ID without having
to put something down all you had to do
is set your beer down I did
after two or three different warnings
and then you want to tell us who you
were or no he did you did as well he did
and tell us about how threatened us with
our jobs I did not do that he did I sat
there and it's like listen guys he was
the first one to flip flip out their
badge
you
I've flipped open my phone to make a
phone call
you flipped it open you're yeah you're
going to hear about this tomorrow well
no he said that I didn't say that I did
not say that he did it's okay it's all
on body cam
good and then it's gonna sit there and
so he's gonna sit there and go it's on
body cam he said that
and then you're gonna sit there and go
oh he's right
once again
and here's another thing is have you
guys not read what's on there yeah I
read it okay but it's not how I see it
ouch
the way I see it is
where's your um
command an officer for right now right
now he's he's inside there the one that
told you to walk away is my commanding
officer
the one that he wanted to argue with he
wasn't arguing with them yes well it's
called also debate
or also called as a late I guess a
lawful command
which I did I put it down I was walking
away I was like hey guys we're all here
just to be here and I was walking away I
was taking a step down and you like
grabbed my arms like whoa I was my left
foot was on the step
I think you guys came here for an
argument or for an instigation because
you rolled up pretty hot
um I was five minutes away from going
home yeah that's exactly what I was I
was coming over here for I would do that
then
I mean if you guys are right there I I'm
looking for an argument and a debate
five minutes before I'm going home
that's not right because you need to go
home exactly but I agree with escalate
it to where we're at now well it wasn't
me escalating anything I was trying to
de-escalate it and you know that I think
he believed that
so that's my boss and my boss's boss
who's the boss over the entire city he's
coming over good
that's what's taking us long
you wanted a supervisor supervisor yep
you come and not stand outside no why
not
may I asked that
because we're not going to stand outside
well
you just detained me correct all right
that is correct and I'm not supposed to
be detained
that's not the way I understand it did
he not read what it said I did read what
it read what it said what did it say
we're not at the state capitol and I'm
not arrested to not say at the state
capitol that's it again like I said
that's that's what this what my
Captain's coming over
to uh while in session
while in session
yeah yeah
yes let's see it that way we are in
session
and even if
you can hypothetically say anything like
I'm walking to the Capitol
I'm walking away from the capitol
but I had a meeting here well actually I
just had a meeting with
the leadership
who's the other two guys that were with
you Representatives what's their names
doesn't matter does it because
hypothetically you just said that you
aren't you said no I'm not detaining you
I'm arresting you I did yes so you're
not even allowed to detain me that you
arrested me
you know if you read the law
you cannot do that right now but you
just did
so congratulations
and that's what he said
not me
[Music]
I sat there and listened to it
just because I don't walk faster than
him or run faster than him
and I was being nice and I was trying to
greet you guys go hey guys how's it
going trying to like say hi what's going
on and all you guys was immediately
attacked
yes you did
and you know it because you had no if
you would just have a conversation
why would you not have a conversation
did you have a conversation
you did not and you know it
you did not have a conversation there
was no conversation exactly yes sir
always a conversation no a command the
lawful command was it's time to go yes
and I said well thank you very much and
like I could have say hey well how's
your night oh you didn't leave so you're
arrested
how was your night just went down sir
are you sure I'm positive oh my God I
know that's the best part I'm gonna love
this because I'm gonna time it
and if there's 30 seconds do you think
it was one minute five minutes was it 30
seconds how long was it
you tell me of how long you got here
when you walked up what you said what
you did
and then within 30 seconds you grab my
arm
because it was 44 seconds
the 44 seconds what do you think is
going to happen
you tell me so you already made up your
mind of what was going to happen correct
because when you walked up
you had an idea of what you were gonna
do but you chose the wrong person
congratulations
this is wrong
44 seconds
dictates what's going to happen right
here right now congratulations oh my God
foreign
this is gonna be good
I will sit there with your captain
and watch that video in a heartbeat open
records Act
I bet it's just less than two minutes
from time you pulled up to where you put
it in because you pulled up rolling hot
oh this is gonna get really good and
that gave every option but you didn't so
I gave the option you didn't
yeah
honestly why'd you guys like just pull
up on here
because someone had to call or say
something
why'd you pick me out of the group
where are we going
pardon where are we going all right
we're going to the county jail
For What republic intoxication uh did
you test me for that
no
so how can I be intoxicated if you
haven't tested me
you think after at 42 years old in the
18 years of being a cop that I don't
know an intoxicated person when I see
one
yes well
maybe the judge will see it that way
um what was I drinking
alcohol no how do you know that because
it was a Coke okay dude I
again stop with your attorney stuff you
can question no I'm being very serious
right you can question me how am I being
detained you're being you're not being
detained you're arrested exactly and I
don't know how many more times I need to
explain to you that yes you are I didn't
have alcohol in My Cup
it was a Coke
and you and I have a conversation
so please tell me
what's truly going on
you're a smart guy yes I am
so what is truly going on
officer what is going on here you're
being arrested for public intoxication
that is what it is for public
drunkenness for how for doing what
again
let me do my stuff and then at that
point what was your assessment
what assessment have you done
you have not done an assessment you have
not done anything
I had Coke in that cup
Coca-Cola
this is the best part this is gonna get
really good
wow
that's receptional Mr Davis
and first of all you have to put the
first name ever wrong
is it in
and I have not spoken with your
supervisor yet which I need to speak
with him he's he's tied up on a call no
I'll wait
your fop officer and your supervisor
need to be called now
do you understand that
how's that even possible
because you never even tested or did
anything
why won't you answer me on that one
there's nothing to answer your speech
it's word you gotta smell I talked that
way
you can't understand or obey simple
instructions simple do a timing of
what's going on it's like yes hey I'm
trying to have a conversation with you
and walk downstairs
that's no
you oh
you did not want assessment not anything
so you guys can make up anything you
want no yeah you did you did
yes sir yes you did
foreign
I'm trying to take care of my friend and
I'm the one that gets arrested this is
funny